good morning John I just sent a Twitter
survey out to my followers asking them
some of their thoughts on starting a
business 15% of those over 18 said that
they'd already started the business 55
percent said they had considered
starting only 11% said that they weren't
at all interested in starting their own
business but while I think there's a
strong entrepreneurial attitude among
young people right now the rate at which
we in America are starting small
businesses and young people in
particular is dropping fast
and the easy thing to do is to put this
on young people themselves are not
interested or we crave the stability of
a normal job or we fear failure and
indeed the social anxiety uncertainty
and fear of failure all showed up high
up in my survey and starting a business
isn't for the faint of heart you have to
take risks you have to jump into stuff
that you don't understand or know very
well you have to do stuff you don't want
to do you have to hire people and you
have to fire people a lot of the time it
sucks to own a business I'd say this is
a person who owns businesses like
there's parts that are not super fun I
think people know that but this very
clearly isn't just about people making
different choices as schools have fought
to attract students the cost of
education has skyrocketed and thus so
has the burden of student debt and that
debt pushes people toward making safer
decisions and maybe toward fearing
failure more in exactly the same way the
skyrocketing costs of health care in
America have made people make safer
decisions when asked what their number
one reason for not starting a business
was about half of people said that that
was a personal choice and about half of
people said it was something structural
and the biggest structural one of course
is just access to capital and the money
things have gotten kind of weird lately
a lot more money is coming from venture
capitalists who are just like super rich
people who basically want their money to
come back ten times so they mostly
invest in tech where there's a lot of
opportunity for huge growth businesses
that probably have a safer path to a
smaller market get ignored and banks are
kind of focusing less and less on the
thing that they're supposed to be doing
which is to help people create new value
in the world mmunity banks now make up
just 13% of the banking sector but they
still make 43 percent of the small
business loans as starting a business
gets more complicated people who have
money might see it as simpler and
probably a better use of their time to
just invest that money in the stock
market meaning in big gigantic
entrenched companies rather than in
their own small business and that's
especially true if you have a lot of
money and more and more of the money is
in
the hands of people who have a lot of if
you have a ton of money starting with
small businesses like an inconsequential
investment in exchange for a whole lot
of water and then the massive amount of
money pumped into the stock market
pushes these gigantic businesses to grow
or die and that results in these massive
behemoths
taking over not just old markets but new
markets the way that Amazon and Netflix
have done meanwhile in the middle-class
wealth has actually decreased so the
people who really want to work their
butts off to make a new thing happen
might not have access to the money to do
that the final reason I'm going to talk
about why young people might not be
starting businesses because I think they
are this is generation 1099 side
hustling contractors people making it
work with a combination of their podcast
their Etsy store their post mates in
their day job every one of those side
hustles is basically a sole
proprietorship if you count that way
this generation is starting up
businesses like never before but the
path to hiring that second person when
all competitive supply chains are global
and when employment regulations and
business taxes are mountains of red tape
it's unclear if it's there at all and if
it is it might just be uninteresting
this isn't a simple story people much
smarter than me are doing much better
research than I have done to look at
this but I want more people instead of
fewer people to know the joy of starting
your own thing of giving somebody else a
job of putting a team together to create
value where there was no value before
you've got thoughts on this or advice on
this or just want to tell us what you
would do if you had access to the
capital you need to do a really looking
forward to the comments on this video
I'll be checking them out all weekend
John I'll see you on Tuesday